your most famous Christmas movie until  now was elf do people scream lines at  you all the time from it yeah there's an  array of different lines from the film  that people will  um anybody else what's your favorite  color people just say to me yeah and I'm  like your buddy though  that I'm buddy yeah and you like to do  that uh Santa I know him people will  scream  and uh you sit on a throne of Lies oh  God yeah my daughters use that on me  every day yeah  I'm assuming these were like improvised  or maybe not yeah I think  I think a fair amount were no having no  news even now you did a lot of writing  on that movie I would guess yeah yeah  yeah beef and cheese was improvised  cheese and beef in the script yeah right  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]